bonjour à tous dans ce nouvel épisode à
la découverte de notre gastronomie
régionale on tente de percer les secrets
de nos grands-mères et aujourd'hui on va
parler de la conservation en bocal on
rejoint tout de suite claire Schneider
et nid à Louis qui vont nous montrer
comment faire
[Musique]
bonjour Claire bonjour Linda alors vous
avez plein de bocaux à nous montrer
aujourd'hui des différentes techniques
de conservation c'est ça donc à
traverser beaucoup on va retrouver
différentes manières de les conserver à
partir de matières premières telles que
le vinaigre l'alcool le sel avec la
lacto-fermentation tout ça c'est toutes
les manières dont on peut faire une
conservation comme nos grand-mères on
pouvait le faire sachant qu'on n'a pas
parlé du séchage avec notamment les
tisanes les herbes que Claire prépare il
y a aussi
cette conserve qui est quand même assez
on le voit plus beaucoup ça racontait
nous un petit peu alors ça c'est j'ai
déjà vu cette conserve réalisée il y a
des années de ça à Vierzon c'est une
grand-mère qui était en train de
dénoyauter les cerises pour un clafoutis
et qui disposait les noyaux des cerises
dans de l'alcool avec du sucre et donc
là vous obtenez une liqueur de noyau
vous pouvez très bien mettre les noyaux
d'abricot les noyaux de cerises et puis
les noyaux de pêche et vous avez même
droit si vous mangez ces noyaux de les
jeter directement dans le bocal c'est
désinfecté avec l'alcool il y a pas
aussi on va rentrer un peu plus dans le
détail sur la lacto-fermentation mais
avant cela toute la matière première ou
en tout cas une grande partie de votre
matière première vous la trouvez ici à
la ferme des Beauregards où nous nous
trouvons on va d'ailleurs regarder ce
reportage réalisé avec Marion tac et
Laurence Bory
ne vous y trompez pas c'est en plein
cœur de la ville de Bourges que se
trouve la ferme des Beauregards une
ferme urbaine et bio qui a vu le jour il
y a 3 ans
sur une micro ferme on cherche à avoir
un autre modèle de production où on
produit plus de diversité et à taille
humaine voilà avec un bien-être au
travail qui est important pour nous
plutôt qu'on type Noah avec une peau
épaisse parce que c'est pour faire des
pickles lacto fermenté
spécialiste de la cuisine locale et
sauvage s'approvisionne chez ce
maraîcher pour ses recettes il y en a
plus loin
la ferme regorge aussi de plantes
sauvages claire Schneider curios
professionnel est venu en renfort
aux allures de chasse au trésor
première tentative ratée les deux
cueilleuses se rabattent sur des prunes
sauvages
mais tu vois en pickles ça peut être pas
mal avec un vinaigre un peu sucré
c'est toujours beaucoup plus agréable
d'aller faire des cueillettes à deux
comme ça on discute et puis on échange
si on ne recettes sur nos sur nos
expériences sur nos connaissances des
connaissances
héritées des grands-mères Berrichonne où
chaque plante à son utilité il n'y a pas
de mauvaises herbes il n'y a que des
herbes qui sont là pour un objectif
particulier parfois c'est vrai qu'elles
peuvent embêter les jardiniers mais si
je prends l'exemple du mouron des
oiseaux qui est une plante sauvage qui
est très envahissante au jardin elle est
absolument délicieuse elle a un goût de
noisette c'est vraiment une très très
bonne plante donc on l'arrache on la
nettoie sur la manche
la ferme des beaux regards a aussi dédié
un nouvel espace de culture au plan de
aromatiques et aux fleurs de quoi
pallier les cueillettes sauvages parfois
incertaine on est de retour avec Linda
Louis et on va apprendre à faire des
concombres lacto-fermentés en bocal
c'est une recette qui consiste à
développer l'acide lactique déjà présent
dans l'air alors déjà on prend des bons
concombres de la ferme on n'a pas besoin
de les éplucher parce que ce qu'on veut
savoir du croquant
donc là on les coupe en petits bâtonnets
une fois qu'on a découpé les légumes on
ajoute du sel faut compter 3% de sel
pour réaliser une saumure
lacto-fermentée 3% c'est 30 g de sel
pour un kilo de légumes
et l'idée c'est de vraiment bien
mélanger parce que si je voulais ajouter
mes concombres directement dans le bocal
j'arriverai pas vraiment à l'état tasser
or l'objectif des bocaux lacto-fermentés
c'est de mettre un maximum de légumes
dans le bocal pour qu'il y ait plus du
tout d'air j'ai fait un petit peu
d'avance ici
là on se rend bien compte que
une heure avant j'ai mis du sel et
regardez je peux faire ça ce qui est pas
du tout le cas en fait avec les
concombres que je viens juste de saler
donc ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va
mettre en bocal directement
ces concombres là
et je vais bien les tasser et là faut
pas oublier les citrons
là je les mets là pour que ça fasse joli
voilà c'est bien tassé après ce que je
vais faire c'est rajouter de l'eau pour
que l'environnement soit vraiment sans
oxygène
on laisse comme ça pendant trois ou
quatre jours à température ambiante et
ensuite on laisse au frigo pendant trois
semaines et au bout de trois semaines on
consommait c'est bon et cette recette on
peut la trouver dans votre livre parce
que vous êtes journaliste et vous
écrivez des ouvrages culinaires en fait
des livres de cuisine basé sur
l'autonomie sur le jardinage le potager
alors je sais pas si on va retomber
dessus alors on peut la trouver donc là
ici
et après on peut couper de plein de
manières on peut couper soit en
rondelles soit en grand bâtonnets et
puis là j'avais ajouté de l'estragon de
la moutarde mais on peut ajouter ce
qu'on veut merci beaucoup en tout cas
lindaoui pour ses astuces et demain
notre page était continue on sera avec
le chef Thomas Parnaud à Chartres qui
nous parlera de céréales oubliés